انا علاء الدالي سكان مدينه رفح قائد فريق
طيور الشامس احنا عباره عن فريق طيور
الشمس كنا من ذوي الاعاقه مطور الاقدام
بنوصل رساله للعالم كله احنا في قدم واحده
ونساعد الناس اليوم نقدم مبادره اللي هي
خضار للناس نزحت من غزه وخل لمدينه رفح
بقدم لهم هذه المساعده الخضروات عباره عن
بندوره وخيار وفنجان وجميع
الخضروات
عاني الدور الخبز على الدور وكل حاجه على
الدور متر من اليهود
و معي جلطه بعد البتر وزعنا طحين برضه
3700 كيلو طحين وعلينا اهالي في الخيام
ومحتاجين بسبب الحرب على غزه نزحوا على
مدينه رفح التي تاوي اكثر من مليون ونص
نازح احنا فريق رياضي لعبه الدراجات
الهوائيه فريق بتر طبعا كل هيته شباب
مطورين حاولنا نشتغل احنا شويه على
السوشال ميديا وعملنا مسار في كذا دوله
اوروبيه ومن خلالها قدرنا احنا نلم بعض
التبرعات اللي على سبت نقدر نقدم فيها
خدمات
وطرود هذ مقدمه من يق الشمس التحديات
والصعوبات من قبلها احنا نجمع هذ الخضره
بجمعها بشكل صعوبي لانه ما فيش خضره في
قطاع غزه خاصه في مدينه رفح لانه اعداد
كبيره
نازحين ساعدنا ان الناس
وتستغرب ان احنا كيف منسوق دراجه برجل
وحده ونتجول فريقنا كامل كان له دراجات في
غزه في
التعاونيه عند شارع الرشيد ك نتدرب عليها
كل دراجاتنا راحت بس احنا وفرنا دراجات من
جديد يعني بصعوبه وفرناها وبعدين نحن
نستمر ونباد ونكمل لشعبنا وهالي شعبنا
الزل احنا مستمرين احنا عباره عن
قوه هيكو مع بعضكن فيها مع بعض ونمشي مع
بعض حتى نوصل هذه المساعدات للنا